If you want to climb the corporate ladder, you'll need connections.
That's why Timmy, Margaret, Jerry and Betty are getting together for a work lunch.
Let's see how it goes.
Not a good start.
Betty is late for lunch.
Timmy, Margaret and Jerry pretend to be okay with it.
But they can barely hide their furious anger.
Their mouths say, "Nice to see you,"...
...but their eyes scream, "Burn in hell."
Look, Timmy ordered a double martini.
He's on his second drink already.
What a lush.
If he doesn't ease up, he'll pass out at the table,...
...which is rarely acceptable at a casual lunch.
Good idea!
Jerry tells a joke to lighten the mood.
Oh Timmy, Jerry's joke isn't that funny.
Timmy's almost pathological laughter is making everyone uncomfortable.
Don't be like Timmy, Margaret, Jerry and Betty.
Work lunch the right way, and you'll be climbing the corporate ladder all the way to the top.